- Hi, everyone, welcome to
the Homeroom live stream.
And we have a really
exciting conversation today
with secretary Arne Duncan,
secretary of education under Barack Obama.
But before we get into that,
I will give my standard announcements.
First of all, just a
reminder that Khan Academy
is a not for-profit.
It can only exist through donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're position to do so,
please think about going
to Khanacademy.org/donate
and making a donation.
I also wanna give a special thanks
to several organizations
that have stepped up
during the COVID crisis.
We were already running a
bit of a deficit pre COVID,
and then you could imagine when covert hit
our traffic went through the roof.
We've been trying to accelerate
programs for students,
teachers, and parents.
And so our deficit only grew.
And so special thanks to Bank of America,
Google.org, AT&T, Fastly, Novartis,
and the many other
supporters big and small
across the board.
Those dollars make a huge
difference in our ability
to serve really the country
and really the planet
keep learning through this
really, really tough period.
Also wanna remind everyone
about the Homeroom with Sal
the podcast, which is, as I said before,
it's a way to consume this live stream
in a way that is safe
while you are driving.
Although you can also consume
it when you are not driving.
So anywhere you get your podcasts,
look up Homeroom with Sal,
it's a slightly modified
version of these live streams.
So with that, I'm excited
to introduce someone
who is an expert on all things education,
someone who I look up to and consider
to be a good friend,
secretary Arne Duncan,
former secretary of education
under the Obama administration
and managing partner of Chicago Cred.
Arne, thanks for joining us.
- I'm thrilled to be here inside.
I just gotta say, just
as a parent, as a dad,
you've been so helpful to my two kids
as they were growing up and
just really, really appreciate
everything you're doing
for millions of kids,
not just across the country,
but across the planet
and whatever I can do
to be helpful to you.
I just wanna be a good teammate
to your extraordinary work, so thank you.
- No, thank you, actually,
obviously we've interacted
many times over the last few years,
but I just had a flashback
to the first time we met,
which was on video conference.
You were secretary of education.
Khan Academy was like only a year.
We were on top of a tea shop
and I had a video conference
with the secretary of education.
So I put on a jacket, I put on a tie,
but by the end of the conversation,
I felt so comfortable
with you that I said,
and they had stopped recording.
I said, Arne, can I tell you a secret?
And, and you said, what?
And I stood up and I was wearing shorts.
And so that was all very
present for the COVID world.
- You've always been ahead of your time.
(Arne laughing)
- I've always been ahead of the time.
I mean, now even shorts I consider formal,
but I, anyway, we don't have to go.
(Both laughing)
So Arne, I mean, maybe
a good place to start.
I mean, we were obviously,
there's through multiple layers
of crises going on.
There's a healthcare crisis,
there's an economic crisis
and there's an education crisis.
And I think those really are
where everyone's minds are.
You've been secretary of education,
if this pandemic were happening in 2012
or actually what, even
earlier when in 2010,
what do you see as the role
for the federal government?
What do you think needs
to happen to make sure
that people keep learning?
- Well, let me just add
to those, unfortunately,
that long list of crises you talked about,
I would just add a health
crisis, a public health crisis
of systemic racism that we are
still trying to reckon with.
And all the inequities
that we know exist across
every part of our society,
education is not exempt from that.
And systemic racism is part and parcel
of our educational system
and happy to talk about this.
So the challenges are many.
And let me be very clear.
We made more than our share of mistakes,
happy to talk about successes,
happy to talk about failures.
What I can tell you Sal
from the bottom of my heart,
as we came to work every single day,
trying to do what was right for children.
And I would say education
is the ultimate bipartisan
issue, nonpartisan issue.
There's nothing political
about more kids having access
to pre-K and raising high
school graduation rates
and having more young
people, go on to college
once they graduate and attracting
and retaining great teachers
and doing more technologies,
you've done so well.
So for me, this has never
ever been about politics.
It's about policy where I promise you,
we would have done is
me and my counterpart
at health and human services
are Kathleen Sebelius,
who was the former governor of Kansas
would have been locked at the hip.
Tom Frieden who ran the CDC.
Who's a remarkable leader
in the medical space.
We would have been locked at the hip.
We would have been very, very transparent
and open and honest,.
As you know information.
We're learning more things every week,
every day we still are.
You have to constantly be
communicating with tremendous
transparency and urgency,
but also humility to the American public.
I promise you,
we would have taken this
extraordinarily seriously.
I promise you, we wouldn't have buried it
like the current administration.
I promise you, we wouldn't
have called it a hoax.
I promise you, we
wouldn't have put a stigma
behind wearing mask.
And it's interesting.
My focus has always been on educating kids
and giving them a chance in
life and trying to break cycles
of poverty through education.
But this has brought another lens.
Our first priority, our
first responsibility
is to keep children and
parents and teachers
alive and safe and healthy.
And so that's the framework
through which we would have
taken on this work every day.
And I will say, I again,
it's just my heart
I'm always honest.
- And Phillip I don't know
if the audio cut out for you.
I'm having trouble hearing
audio all of a sudden.
Are you seeing, can you hear me Arne?
Let me see what's going on
with my, let me see what's
let me see what's going on with the audio.
Philip if you send me
a message, let me know
if is it on my end?
Is it on secretary Duncan's end.
We're having a audio situation.
Bear with us for one second, okay.
It sounds like you can hear us.
Okay, so I will keep going.
I know now that I know
that you can hear me,
so maybe secretary
Duncan, will jump back in.
But anyway, I'm largely
looking at the questions.
I have a bunch of really
interesting questions
that are coming in from
folks generally speaking.
And I definitely have
some followup questions
for secretary Duncan, but I
encourage it while we're waiting
everyone to go on YouTube or Facebook
or wherever you are
watching this and fill in
and put any questions that
you have for secretary Duncan
or myself on a literally anything.
And as soon as he comes back,
I'll be sure to get as many of
those questions as possible.
And I don't know the
timing of him coming back.
So you can ask me questions.
You can ask me questions as well.
I'm hoping we can get this
cause this so many things
I wanna ask him.
Let's see, where is,
so let's Shrin Shivash
Novi rather Krishnan.
Why do you think what you're
doing is helping kids like me?
Well, I hope it's
helping students like you
because that's the whole
goal of Khan Academy
for that any student, whether
they're in a classroom
or outside of the classroom
to really be able to learn
at their own time and
pace and fill any gaps
that they have at their
knowledge get mastery.
And as you build that muscle
of practice on Khan Academy,
I think inherently all
human beings we wanna learn.
And so the more that you get
to do that and exercise that,
I think you'll just
somewhat get addicted to it.
And obviously if you
get addicted to learning
you're going to be very well empowered,
the rest of your life.
People who are auto learners are the ones
that are really
unstoppable in our society,
especially society that index
is more and more on learning.
Let's see other feel
free to ask any questions
that are coming in.
I think we might've had
a technical drop-off
with secretary Duncan.
- I can hear you.
- Oh, good, good, you're there.
Okay, perfectly we're we're back.
All right, now I heard your last question
then it clipped out and I
wasn't sure if it was my fault
or your fault or the
Internet's fault, who knows?
It's all, probably let's
blame it on the internet.
So Arne, what is, if you, well,
if you were whatever the
next administration is,
if you found yourself or you're advising
the next secretary of education,
what levers are there at the federal level
to help us as we go
through what's hopefully
a short few months of continuing
kind of this COVID strangeness,
and then what needs to happen after COVID
to make sure that the
damage isn't long lasting
and what can you do at the federal level?
That's what's always really interesting.
What can the secretary of
education really do here?
- Well, there's so much
that that the next
administration has to do.
And let me just give you a
couple of different things
to think about.
I will always start with pre-K
that we have to get our
babies off to a good start.
For me that's the best
investment we can make.
We gotta stop.
- Arne the producer saying,
if you can tilt the camera a little bit,
so I'd want to cut it down a little bit.
You're getting cut off by your name.
There you go, perfect, okay.
Sorry, I didn't wanna.
- Is that, is that okay?
- Much, much, much better,
yes, sorry I didn't wanna.
- You got to work on the
technical side of this stuff.
- People are still
behind the scenes today.
- I'd start with a massive
investment in pre-K
and getting more and more children
across the country ready for school.
Secondly, we have to
close the digital divide.
Next administration could
do that with the FCC.
We gotta make access to devices, to wifi,
to the internet, as
ubiquitous, as electricity
and drinking water kids have
to be able to learn anything
they want, anytime, anywhere,
inner city communities, rural communities,
suburban communities, native
American reservations.
That has to be the norm.
We have to think very differently
as you and I have talked
about the school day,
the school year, the
calendar having summer off
for everybody doesn't make sense.
We have a lot of kids
that need to catch up.
You'll lengthening the time
which kids have a chance
to learn is so important.
I think we have to think
differently about the length
of time we ask kids to go to school.
We've had a kindergarten
through 12th grade model.
That's worked well for
the last a hundred years.
I don't think it's suited
well at all for the next five
or 10 years, let alone the next 20 or 30.
I think we have to move to
a pre-K through 14 model
and make that the norm.
And then finally, for those kids
that have been most
impacted by the COVID slide
and then summer slide,
and then may not be back
at school this fall.
And that can literally be a
couple million kids South.
So these are not small numbers.
I would love to see a
national tutoring initiative
where we can work with
those children physically,
virtually to try and help them catch up.
We can't allow them to have a lost year
'cause if we lose a year,
we may lose them forever.
And so there's so much that
the next administration
has to do work with
tremendous urgency invest.
I would say a great deal.
A great military is our best defense,
but a great educational systems,
our best offense as a country,
we need an administration
that truly understands
that we have to invest in kids
and ultimately in our families
and our communities in our country.
- And I couldn't agree
more with pretty much
everything you just said.
I mean, just taking them one
by one the digital divide,
that's one, you and I
have talked a lot about,
obviously even to start
accessing Khan Academy
and other resources, or just participating
in digital learning or
distance learning, you need it.
What's your sense of what
it would take to get,
make it so like no family in the country
does not have sufficient internet access,
just like clean drinking, water
heating like you mentioned,
my back of the envelope calculations,
it's a 1% of the trillion,
that we're throwing around
a stimulus right now.
And it seems like everyone's behind it.
So what takes us across the finish line?
- Yeah, what would always, I
guess, get both gives me hope,
but frankly, infuriates me is Sal.
This is not like a cure for cancer.
This is not putting a man on Mars.
This is simply a lack of vision.
A lack of political
will, a lack of courage
and frankly, a lack of caring
about our nation's kids.
So the amount of money would
be a couple of billion dollars,
whatever we'll figure
out what that number is.
It is not overwhelming.
You have the FCC and
E-Rate that has access
to billions of dollars that could be used
in a different way.
And so the, the funding
issue here to your point
is basically a rounding era.
It's just believing in
kids and understanding
that we need help every
child, wherever they are,
find their genius, find
what they love to do.
Find what they want to
do with their lives.
And I say all the time that
talent is evenly distributed
in our country, opportunity is not,
we've got to close the opportunity gap.
We've got to make sure
opportunity meets that talent
wherever and everywhere that it is.
- Arne in terms of federal levers,
cause this is something
know I'm always told.
And my understanding is that
most of education spending
is happening at the state level,
but clearly we have a federal
department of education.
And it seems like for things like to get
digital divide funds, which right.
I mean, my back of the envelope,
it's at most 10 $20 billion,
which is a large number
for individual people,
but it is a small percentage
of the stimulus type numbers
that have been going out there.
That seems like an obvious
thing where the federal
department of education
could play a big role.
What about these other things
that you're talking about?
Allow changing the school
year, which I agree,
full year's full day schooling,
having tutoring programs,
et cetera, et cetera.
What is an, I'm not sure
if we lost Arne just now.
I don't, I'm not seeing him anymore.
Well, I'll keep asking the question.
What are the federal levers
that we have for that?
Maybe we just have such a good question.
Well, y'all are seeing the roast things
that can go wrong when you're
doing distance communication.
- I'm back, I'm back.
- There you go.
You're really, did you get my question?
- No, sorry, you cut out.
I couldn't hear you, I apologize.
- My bad, well, we'll
blame the internet again.
The question was digital divide.
That seems like a no brainer
from a federal department
of education, point of view.
It's a small percentage
of the multi trillions
of stimulus that we're putting out there.
These other things that you talked about,
like the school day, the calendar,
allowing for competency-based learn.
I don't think you said it,
but I've heard you say other
times say things like that
or a tutoring program, can that
happen at the federal level,
or is that something
that kind of the federal
can influence the States to do?
- Yeah, both of those, all of the above.
So let's sort of take it one at a time.
So for me, the E-Rate, the E-Rate program,
that's a federal program,
that's at the national level.
And again, this is a national crisis.
It has to be a national initiative.
So you do that.
Closing the digital divide.
We can't leave that locality by locality
community by community, state by state.
We need to do that for every
kid now, why are we waiting?
What are we waiting for?
So that leadership has to happen there.
I think, is something like
a national tutoring program
and what you're getting going in terms
of the volunteer initiative
is extraordinarily important.
I just wanna help you do
that and see that scale,
that leadership come
with the federal level,
more resources for pre-K that
can come at the federal level.
We invested during the
Obama administration,
more than a billion dollars in pre-K
is one of the things I was most proud of.
We just need to do more of that and work
with Congress to do that.
Some of the stuff, as you
said, is very, very local
thinking differently about
the calendar, the school day,
the school week, summers,
thinking about a pre-K through 14
model for education in America,
rather than K through 12.
Those are things that
absolutely would need to happen
at the local level, but what
the federal government could do
is they could provide
resources to help people
think about those things,
help them model it,
try and scale it, learn
what works, what doesn't,
you have an amazing
opportunity always to convene
at the federal level,
to put resources behind
innovation and creativity.
And so, again, whether it's hard dollars
in some of this stuff or
just leadership and vision
at the federal level,
that you can play an
extraordinarily important part
in helping give kids a chance in life.
- Now, that makes a lot of sense.
And we're, I mean, told by
our technical team, Arne,
if you just touch your
screen every now and then
it might be because your iPad
is going into screensaver mode.
So just, give it a little
love every every few minutes
it'll be good.
So we're getting a ton of questions.
There's a question from
Scott Yang saying, yo Sal,
when can things return to normal
and I'm going to extend it 'cause I think,
Scott is referring to normal
in the school system broadly.
And obviously you referred
to this the notion
of teachers aren't feeling
safe, fully protected.
We clearly don't have a vaccine out there.
What are you hearing as the best practices
that school districts are
doing to navigate these times?
Some people are fully open.
Some people aren't, some
people are kind of hybrid.
What would you advise the
school district right now
to get up and running?
- Couple of thoughts.
First of all, school districts,
schools, they're not
islands, they're not bubbles.
They exist in community.
And so the best thing, if
we truly care about kids,
the best thing we can do
is to beat down this virus
in our communities.
And we have not done a good job of that.
We've lacked discipline.
We've opened bars before
we opened schools,
which didn't make any sense.
I think the way we have to
think about this has gotta
be public health first,
public education second,
and then reopening the economy third,
it's gotta be in that
order, public health,
public education, reopening economy.
We've done that all backwards
with disastrous results.
That's the most important thing we can do.
The second thing I'll say is
that I think school districts
in the absence of federal leadership
have shown just unbelievable,
creativity in doing this,
how you open carefully,
how you open slowly,
how you open with the most
vulnerable children first
or the youngest children's first,
we're seeing fantastic
examples around the country.
As you notice Sal, we
haven't seen big outbreaks,
where districts are opening
up, they're doing it carefully.
They're doing it thoughtfully.
Kids are really adhering to wearing mask
and social distancing.
We've seen frankly, less of
that at the college level
in higher education.
And so schools, I think
are leading the way
in terms of how we get there.
The final point I'll make,
and this is a really important one to me.
I don't wanna go back to "normal"
because normal didn't serve millions
of children well enough.
That's not a high enough bar.
We have to use this time to
reimagine, reinvent education,
do it through a lens of equity.
What's fair, what's just,
how do we close these opportunity gaps?
How do we give every child
a chance to be successful?
And we have to use this
very, very dark time
to try and leapfrog to
something to be much better
for our 53, 54 million
children across the country
who're going to school.
- Yeah, that makes sense.
What's your sense?
When we talked a lot of
districts, even the ones
that have been able to mostly
close the digital divide,
they're also talking,
I have a school teacher who shares
the cul de sac in our neighborhood.
She teaches fifth grade and
this isn't a middle income,
upper middle income neighborhood.
She's telling me that in her class of 30
there's two or three kids
that are just disengaged
and she thinks they have internet access,
but maybe they're don't
have the supports at home.
And what we're hearing in
large urban school districts
is the problems much, much worse.
Even when there is internet access,
how do we reach those
kids, or what do they need?
What kind of support can we give them?
- Yeah, that's so important.
And let me say first that we
have so many in school systems
and individual schools,
you have so many
different responsibilities
and it's not just the education part.
Now I will come back and answer that.
The first thing that schools
do across the country
is they serve tens of millions of kids.
Two, sometimes three meal a day.
And throughout the pandemic,
starting in early March,
we've done a weekly call
with school districts
across the country
who through all of this, as
physical buildings shut down,
those schools continue to
be food distribution centers
and drive throughs in front of it,
just amazing leadership and
hard work to make that happen.
Secondly, we have to take care
of kids' social and emotional health.
And so tele-health teachers,
counselors, psychologists,
social workers, reaching out to children.
Many of whom are dealing with
a lot of trauma before this.
Many of whom are dealing
with unfortunately,
a lot more trauma now, due to pandemic,
due to economic insecurity,
due to systemic racism,
due to food insecurity, we have
to take care of those kids.
And then we get to the education part.
So as we talk about, so
much, high tech and internet
and broadband, all of that's great.
But to answer your question directly,
the most important thing
I think we can do now
to reach those kids who
may have disappeared,
who are struggling,
we have to go old school,
we have to go visit them at their homes.
And it's been fascinating
with a young man.
I worked with here in Chicago
trying to reduce violence
on the South and West sides.
The past few months, I spent
more time than I ever have
on port steps and just
sitting and talking to guys,
at their house, on their
block, in their neighborhood.
I have to say, it's been an
amazing learning experience
and just not sitting behind a desk,
not having them come to our offices,
although we're glad you'll slowly
be able to have physical opposites,
but just meeting them where
they are and listening
and getting a sense of what's going on
has been invaluable in building our trust
and building our relationships.
And so there's no substitute
for again, teachers,
whoever is, again, maybe
not in the playbook
in the traditional playbook,
but this has done not
very nontraditional time.
I would just strongly
urge, not just teachers,
but educational leaders
to go find those kids,
go to their homes, talk to
them, talk to their parents,
find out what's going on,
find out what we can do
to help them reengage.
And I always say, when
kids are struggling,
when they're not able to
participate in school,
when their behavior isn't great
for me, that's always
a symptom of a problem.
The problem is much deeper
and we got to not deal
with the symptoms here.
We got to deal with the root
causes, whatever they may be.
- Now, it makes a ton of sense.
And you alluded to it.
I mean, tell us a little
bit about the work
that you're doing now at Cred.
What is at work?
Why have you kind of put your,
you could be doing anything
in education or beyond.
Why are you focusing your energies there?
- Yeah, so I'm obsessed,
just laser focused on reducing
gun violence in Chicago
and I'll tell you.
So I started to lose
friends to gun violence
when I was a teen, I'm 55.
And how so that's 40 years ago.
Honestly, I think, when that happens,
it shapes you and probably
scars you in some ways,
a little bit difficult to talk about.
During my time leading the
Chicago public schools,
there's a whole bunch of
really, really proud of.
We can talk about that all day,
but on my watch during
my seven and a half years
leading the Chicago
public schools on average,
we had one of our children,
one of our students killed
every two weeks due to gun violence.
It was a staggering rate of loss
and thank goodness, it
was never in school,
but it was going home on the bus,
walk into the corner store,
shot through a living room
window, 7:30 in the morning,
getting ready for school.
And I just feel, I don't
feel, I know we as adults
fail to keep our kids safe.
And when our family moved to DC in 2009,
very naively in hindsight,
I thought we were rock bottom.
I thought we couldn't get any
worse in terms of violence
and for a whole a whole host of reasons,
things got a lot worse than
seven years, we were in DC.
So coming back home, Chicago
has given me every opportunity,
educationally academically, athletically,
socially, culturally, I
owe this city everything
for me to come back here and not deal
with this crisis didn't feel right.
So we're just working
directly with a young men
in the South and West sides,
most likely to shoot and be shot
and helping them move out of that life
and start to be the real
strong community leaders
they need to be to take our city
to a much safer place.
The level of fear and
trauma that our children
are growing up with on the
Southwest side is unimaginable.
And it's not right.
It's not fair, it's not their fault.
And we're trying to break those cycles.
- Well, what do you
think is the major lever?
I mean, you talked about
just that door to door work,
making connections with young people.
Is that really the core work
or are there other levers?
- Yeah, this work is
very, very complicated,
so I don't wanna ever oversimplify.
So I'll just say there are five.
What we call five pillars to our work.
So one is street outreach.
We have guys who formerly
were in the gangs
and the cliques who have what we call
LTO licensed to operate, who
they work to mediate conflicts.
And actually it's crazy this past weekend,
Saturday night, one of our
street outreach workers
actually successfully
negotiated a hostile situation.
The police stood down
and let him handle it
because he had to let the relationship
was unbelievable there.
So we have street outreach that basically
is our HR function.
They bring young men into our program.
Once guys come to us,
we do four other things.
Every guy has a life coach.
We always say experience
can be the best teacher,
but doesn't have to be your experience.
Our life coaches have lived
often very tough lives,
but I've come out the back
end and want to give back
and want to help out, they're remarkable.
We have a clinical team.
The amount of trauma our guys
are dealing with is extraordinary.
We see all the time that
hurt people, hurt people.
We have to help guys heal and deal
with a lifetime of trauma.
We have an education team
with had well over a 100 guys,
get high school diplomas.
We have a set of folks
actually in college now,
and it's been fantastic
to see that happen.
And then we have a jobs
team and ultimately
our goal is to move guys
out of the street economy,
into the legal economy.
And we have a jobs teams that
helps in that transition.
Guys worked with us for nine
months, a year, 15 months.
Now we have about four
dozen employers who hire
at the back end.
And so those are the five pillars
that give us a chance to
give guys a chance in life.
And I would say after a few
we've given them not a second
chance, but a first chance.
- Now, that's incredibly powerful,
incredibly important work.
One question here,
I know we're running low
on time from Facebook,
Carl James Mark Hart.
It's about higher education, with the cost
of university education in
the States at a record high
and with COVID-19 demonstrating the extent
to which university
education is self-taught
when online resources
are readily available,
how can the next government improve access
to cost effective tertiary education,
which lead to accredited qualifications,
which are valued by employers?
Big question
- Yes, I think this pandemic is forcing us
to be creative and think very
differently about education.
So what can be delivered,
not just what can be delivered online.
Maybe what's even better
delivered more effectively,
more efficiently delivered online.
We're gonna come out of this much smarter
than we went into this,
where, how we utilize
our best teachers, whether it's K to 12,
our best professors on
the higher education side,
again, what you've done
and what you did for our,
my kids said you're,
you're an amazing teacher.
You didn't teach 25 kids in one class
or 120 freshmen or sophomores.
You've touched tens of millions of kids.
And how do we create systems
where our best instructors
in whatever it is, have more range,
have more access to young people.
Again, whether it's K to 12
or in the on the higher end side.
I think as I said earlier, as a country,
we have to move to a pre-K to 14 model.
Not everyone has to go to
a four year university,
but I want to make sure
they have the opportunity to do that.
And so we just have to make
sure every young person
coming out of high school
get four year university,
two year community college,
technical vocational training
that they have a plan beyond that.
I think we will see more low cost,
high quality models coming
out of higher education.
Again, the federal government
could do a lot more
to incentivize that and put
some resources behind that.
And then the final thing
I would love to see
the federal government do
is where we're seeing universities.
The goal for me is not to
just enroll young people
is to have them graduate,
is to get that diploma.
And the worst thing you can
have is all that college debt
and no degree, that's the worst position.
But if you graduate, you're
gonna be in pretty good shape.
And so I think again,
at the federal level,
we can incentivize those
universities are those new models
where, whether it's
English language learners,
whether it's Pell recipients,
whether it's first
generation college goers
or all of the above,
who's doing the best job,
not just again of attracting
them, of enrolling them,
but helping them graduate.
I'd like to put a lot more resources
behind those traditional institutions
or new creative institutions
that are emerging and
frankly, less resources behind
those places that aren't as
serious about helping people
get that piece of paper that's
so critically important.
- Now, it's all about transparency.
Not only are they graduating,
but what are their job
placement, et cetera.
So this next question,
there has been a lot of
conversation on social media
about your background.
This is my serious question from Facebook,
Ruth Brannigan asks, where is Arne?
Was it his turn to bowl?
I think that is in reference(mumbles).
- Is it my turn to what?
- Bowl, I think they think what's behind
your are bowling shoes.
(Arne laughing)
That's like a nice bowling
alley, that's a nice view.
- I don't wanna see any bowls.
I'll tell you the folks
who's are kind enough
to give our nonprofit office space here.
It's actually an interesting story.
They bronze the shoes of the
mentors of all the people
who work at their company
and basically said,
we built this company upon your shoulders.
So they bronze the actual
shoes of the mentors
of all of their employees
here so that the company
gives you spaces Vistria
and he has a pretty remarkable story.
And people come visit.
People often go show them
that the shoe of their mentor,